okay wait
[Applause]
let's get ready for the rescue
my memories of this rescue are vivid
because it was a whirlwind we'd only
come onto the Geo Barons the night
before and we were supposed to spend the
whole morning practicing on board these
These are the rigid inflatable rescue
boats there are two of them that one's
called uh Orca the other one is Mike but
we were called in after just 30 minutes
of preparation because of course there
was a real rescue on the way remember
the PA announcement telling us to get
ready so we rushed up here this is the
kit that I was using the helmet life
jacket the over trousers got those on in
a hurry and then rushed out through the
doors on either side then the memories
are kind of snapshot I remember the
speed of approaching the boat the shock
of seeing just how many people were
holding on to the side of it then the
first load we got onto the boat that I
was helping on I remember a man hugging
me I can feel his bristles on the side
of my face a woman who fainted right on
top of me I remember the crying of a
baby okay and also but even after we've
done two or three Journeys taking off
maybe 150 people the boat's still
looking absolutely packed took about
three hours to complete but that of
course was only the start for many
people here it then turned into a care
mission rather than a restaurant that is
why we're wearing Hospital scrub because
over there
are 606 people waiting to arrive in
Italy
thank you